hi there
my name is Greg Greg Alba and my name is
John John is here today we're gonna
watch the trailer for a movie that John
is very much excited for it's called
don't breathe it's Freddy fede fede
alvarez fede alvarez the guy who did the
Evil Dead remake I want to watch this it
stars that guy from goosebumps wears one
Jack buck you know I don't mean jack you
know which one the the protagonist the
strapping young lad goes we just play
trip let's look for that's how you're
making a cash out there
what do you say you and I move away from
up together it's a promise
believing yeah as soon as I have the
money are you coming back never
kill here I got our ticket out of here
keifa is this guy is sitting on at least
300 cake oh that's her guy wait is he
blind I messed up to rob a blind guy
isn't it just cuz he's blind don't mean
he's a saint bro true true money's
probably in there nice what she'd that
smooth there stay right there
you a spy daredevil buddy matter let me
go
whoa
our tractor has to be way out of here
really good now you're gonna see what I
see
interesting
well done that looks crazy well done I
was watching that cuz I was like look
this guy's dead oh my god I was gonna
make that joke I'm gonna start kicking
his ass and I was like oh [ __ ] but boy
your [ __ ] idea do you can't breathe
you gotta watch yourself around a blind
guy who can possibly kick your ass
while he's and it seems like he's
systematically trapping them a little
bit more with these passes I'm
interested to see how they're gonna pull
it off this is gonna have to have some
very tight you know plotting but if they
could do it man that looks awesome
plus like the whole like filming in the
dark thing guy start realized like they
must have probably shot them in pitch
blackness with cameras that could pick
them up or something with like infrared
or something that yeah and that looks
really cool I'm always excited when I
war movie you know kind of brings a new
thing like that into the arena me yeah
that's a terrifying idea in a lot of
ways because especially I mean for
someone who is a big fan of that show
daredevil yeah I'm like damn blind
people have some heightened senses from
my understanding now this guy's exactly
Matt Murdock but you know he has that
physical like presence that you know is
blind guy works out and he does martial
arts and stuff and what was that thing
with that girl that the in the bottom of
the who attacked nothing no idea what
that was for that was really strange I
really think they just can't outrun like
the neon like run away well I'm curious
about that I don't know I really wonder
how smell that is that's to be like one
of those like really clever scripts you
know to really make it work yeah this is
one of the things where I'm like okay
yeah I want to see how this could work
and it looks like it could yeah I know
in a lot of ways it is like those it's
like a home invasion movie in a lot of
ways you know it's like panic room and
with this I don't know it sounds like he
kind of wants people to you know go
after him I don't know about that that
and I kind of hope it's not that I hope
he's not like he goes outside to lure
people in because they got I forget that
actor's name but they got stash Steve
Lang is it stealing yeah
they have Stephen Lang who like you know
he looks like a guy who used to be in
the military who's just devoted his
Spartan life to working out and go into
the grocery store and you know vaguely
contributing every day he looks like the
kind of guy who might have just kept up
all these crazies
despite having lost his sight again it's
like it's a smart casting choice so if
again if the script is tight enough that
could really work cuz there's another
movie out right now called hush that
deals with I think it's a killer guy
breaks into a deaf girl's house and it's
a little more horror movie like he's got
masks and stuff like that and it's it's
a cat mouse thing whereas this looks
like kind of a more weird realistic spin
on it or something a little less horror
moving a little more like oh they just
[ __ ] with the wrong guy and here's
what happens I would have preferred um
you know a protagonist actually you know
what no they did it the right way I mean
it would have been interesting to like
see a set up of all three of them are
like pretty much bad people you know
like as so far as only k-fed who's like
a bad guy but the other two are you know
well it seems like a feds bad Dan levy
is like yeah she's been Billy it's like
kind of bad but not all bad the guy from
goosebumps is like the guy from
goosebumps like two years from now this
is a great choice room to follow up
goosebumps with you know you do a horror
comedy and now you're doing like a
horror film like this is a great trend
it's a good transition there's a rule of
three for all the macker out there he
did it he did like a family one and now
he's doing like you know like a record
yeah
and a I'm really excited to see Jane
leaving back again I it took me a second
to realize who that was and the Evil
Dead remake you know when you look back
at fede alvarez this version of it the
violence might be overshadowing a lot of
just a natural suspense yeah and I feel
like this one's not gonna rely so
heavily on violence that it's gonna
actually be like I'm excited to see him
just explore more with you know
suspenseful territory and creating
tension and stuff yeah and I hope that
that's what this is like I hope this is
kind of like when James Wan jumps from
saw to insidious yeah and I know there
are a few films in between there that
was when he came back it was like hey
check it out I'm not only gonna make
this like you know a different kind like
a spooky ghost movie
there's gonna be blood it's gonna be
pg-13 it's still gonna be [ __ ]
terrifying so I hope that he can that
that's what he can kind of do with this
you know yeah sort of prove like yeah we
did the Pope egoriy thing and now we're
gonna do something that's just a nifty
idea and a lot of tight suspense well
guys listen if you're new to the channel
do me a favor see the subscribe button
click it it'll be worth your time
maybe my John yeah let's play this
called reasons Jerry on here check it
out and John is the social media manager
over at blue house comm she'd go check
out her side to John's really on top of
that
hey no he doesn't ask did I do my job he
does what he has to do I yeah yeah he
goes above and beyond
I always gloom a so if you're watching
you from Motown Jason blue if you're
watching we can be friends don't worry
John I'm not going to make a sex chair
towards Jason no thank you for sharing
me of that